a lot of people including myself have
found the study of world war one to be a
little bit confusing sometimes and i
think the reason is that the world was
very different leading up to world war
one than it is today to some degree the
modern world we live in was shaped to a
large degree by world war one and then
later world war ii and just to get a
sense of what our modern world looks
like and especially what modern europe
looks like this is a map of modern
europe but the interesting thing about
this map is instead of being the
traditional map that you normally see
where you just see the country
boundaries the state boundaries this has
the state boundaries right here in these
little gray lines they show the
where where france ends and say
switzerland or germany or italy begins
but overlaying on top of that we see
where the languages are spoken so this
is actually much more focused on where
do people speak french where does people
speak german and the thing that you will
notice is for the most part throughout
most of europe
today's boundaries the modern boundaries
closely closely match up to where
languages are spoken there are a few
areas where this isn't there's a there
is more of a disconnect with catalan and
spanish and actually that is leading to
some issues but for the most part in
modern europe the country boundaries and
the linguistic boundaries or the
national boundaries kind of match up
if we go if we rewind to the world of
entering into world war one things were
very different some of the boundaries we
recognize we recognize we recognize the
united kingdom as
well ireland has since been carved out
but we recognize it as not being that
different than it is today spain is not
that different france is not that
different italy is not that different
germany is a good bit different in fact
if you take germany the german empire
entering or entering into world war one
or the early 1900s around 1914 between
them and the russian empire they
essentially they essentially were we're
swallowing up a bunch of linguistic
groups a bunch of linguistic groups
right over here that now have their own
independent states
the other thing that you might notice is
this huge this huge state called
austria-hungary or often called the
austro-hungarian empire and people say
well you know there's
you know i'm familiar with some of these
nations that have the word austrian
hungry in them but i'm not you know what
is this austro-hungarian empire and
what's interesting about it it really
was an empire it was really trying to
cobble together all of these folks that
spoke all different all different types
of ethnicities this is kind of a zoom in
of the austro-hungarian empire leading
into world war one and the
austro-hungarian empire
is probably the most important thing to
understand if we're trying to get a
sense of how world war one started
because leading up to world war one in
1908 the austro-hungarian empire
formerly annexed bosnia and herzegovina
and that's another confusing thing for
many of us that that's actually one
country it's called bosnia and
herzegovina or i guess for the
austro-hungarians that was i guess now
one region that they annexed and what's
interesting about that is if you look at
the linguistic map you see that this
whole region right over here speaks a
very similar essentially their dialects
of serbian croatian bosnian they're all
very linguistically and ethnically
connected so this whole region right
over here this whole region right over
here is linguistically and ethnically
connected and what we'll see is is that
this desire to to connect people with
similar ethnic or linguistic routes was
a
backgrounds is what led to a lot of what
happened in world war or at least was
the spark that fueled that people
sometimes say the powder keg of world
war one
the other thing that was very different
or the other i guess country or nation
or empire that we are not used to today
is the ottoman empire so if we go today
we see the country of turkey which is
kind of on the anatolian peninsula so
this is turkey
this is turkey right over here this is
modern-day turkey but entering into
world war one in 1914 turkey was
essentially part of the remnants of the
ottoman empire so this right over here
is what the ottoman empire looked like
this is this is right over here is
roughly modern-day turkey but the
ottoman empire consisted of modern-day
turkey and much of the modern middle
east so much of especially much of the
arab especially the arab world around
syria iraq
lebanon
lebanon
much of what where modern-day israel is
some of saudi arabia
and this was really the dying state of
the ottoman empire at its peak it
controlled much of the muslim world it
controlled northern africa as well as
all the stuff that you see here and even
a little bit and even a little bit of
persia and actually a good bit of the
balkan southeast europe and even greece
at the peak of its ottoman empire now
i'm talking about going hundreds and
hundreds of years back into the past so
when we enter into world war ii we don't
have a world where people kind of are
where states are defined by linguistic
boundaries or by ethnic boundaries to a
large degree we had these empires that
had existed that had existed as we
exited out of the 1800s and these
empires were not just in europe like the
austria the austro-hungarian empire or
not just in the middle east like the
ottoman empire right over here is a kind
of an empire map at around that point in
time
and you see
probably the most dominant feature here
is the british empire
that's in this pink color so british
that's great that's the united kingdom
great britain would just be would just
be this right over here you throw in
ireland you get the united kingdom
great britain was in control of the
indian the entire indian subcontinent it
was essentially
although nominally egypt had was
somewhat independent great britain had a
huge amount of influence here obviously
places like canada and
australia and new zealand were under
control of or part of the british empire
what a lot of people don't realize is a
significant amount of africa as well a
significant amount of africa was also
was also under british control and what
we have running up into
world war one
is kind of a a race for empire an arms
race between the major powers of europe
in particular you have great britain or
or the united kingdom that obviously had
a vast empire the sun never sets on the
british empire and it wasn't ever
setting on this empire that we just saw
here and the german empire was also
starting to flex its muscle and starting
and starting to militarize and the more
that the germans saw that the british
were militarizing the more that the
british and the more that the british
the more the germans would want to
military militarize and vice versa and
you just had this arms race and they
were all trying to build their empires
so the germans they were they were
present in africa you have the french
who were in president in much of africa
and you have to remember all of this in
context some of this empire building was
frankly just about ego
and just about spreading someone's
influence subsiding their power
a lot of it was based on kind of ethnic
beliefs about civilization i guess these
were rationalizations to kind of take
control of other people's resources and
a lot of it was we were in a world where
access to resources in particular access
to raw materials and especially oil
could to some degree define whether a
a power was a power at all and so with
that i think we have a pretty good basis
for
the state of affairs as we enter into
world war one